but first this is Shaun Donovan Big Sean
Sean Don hey Tommy hey Brian
I got a king under stinking tortilla
Tommy and restaurants big fan Applebee's
Chili's those types of places just want
to know what you guys thought all Sophie
oh you look like the live rendition of
sweet little Brendan you look like John
Travolta in hairspray that mouths
brother mouth in his hilarious it's
gonna be a circus mouth um chain
restaurants I don't really like it
myself but I have to go off on the road
let me tell you something the go-to will
blow your goddamn mind TGI Fridays dude
their rack of ribs comes correct I've
been all over this goddamn beautiful
nation trying to barbecue TGI Fridays
dude and the sampler platter you have
yourself a good old night you [ __ ] your
pants in the hotel but it's fun while
you're doing it bro you're not gonna
come correct what you're gonna come
freaking you're gonna be a d-plus
student if you come in correct with
chilies and their magic or whatever
that's not a choice out TGI Fridays
maybe I want my baby my baby my Chili's
know that dude I'll dish him for that
commercial and it got down to me and
like two other dudes know I did it yeah
damn barbecue sauce
they're like can you sing it like and I
couldn't tell the difference between
singing and saying something I couldn't
figure it out at the moment
and I was like Chili's baby back ribs
yeah I'm gonna give you that right Wow
yeah no cheating
my brain
my brain hit a u-turn or somewhere he
got cold a second browse coldest bro
you're not you and like that's great in
order just sing it for us we need you to
sing it and you're just gonna couldn't
do it Chili's baby back ribs
sounds like you're Bruce Buffer
announcing your ribs oh man
in my own corner back at my house that's
where I ended up this is what happened
here bro this man is asking about this I
think i'ma go with um no chain
restaurants in general de GI Friday's
put all that they put that once they
went Jack Daniels on everything I was
out no that's out bro you're you're
confusing with Chili's bro I know didn't
get the commercial but don't get it
twisted also another chain Hooters have
some crispy wings stare at tits boom
nice little parlay of a day also Outback
Steakhouse my grandma passed away
we stood go there I get a nice little 8
ounce sirloin and she would steal the
steak knife really yeah every time I was
young man that's beautiful man I love
picturing that older woman putting
knives in her approach but and they go
qui you some more knives and they never
figure it out like where the [ __ ] you
think all these me my grandma you've
dropped seven knives off melt them down
make a sword at home yeah we had a ton
of them
ah if I got to go to a chain restaurant
brah go to McDaniels brought in the
middle of the night dog sitting down
having a meal talking to your friend
I'll go to freaking Chili's bro I don't
mind going to Applebee's but I don't
really like Applebee's out are they out
of business no they're still in the
neighborhood friendly whatever the [ __ ]
it's gone yeah do you mind Bennigan's
yeah yeah they're out Bennigan's is out
yeah ventually they all fold man I'll go
to a perk and I'll go to chilly
three calendars see yeah cuz only me it
was [ __ ] pies all the gut in pies a
glass a seasonal thing bro now for some
people who Thanksgiving you would that
who are you with that pumpkin I'm Kim
yeah oh yeah you put a little whipped
cream on top yeah I feel like I get a
little bit older I get that pumpkin
here's something now owls for children
older
yeah apples for [ __ ] [ __ ] now that
I'm older though dude you know I do and
I get a nice pecan pie a nice robust
coffee dude pecan pie and coffee that's
that old man gang she's doing robe nuts
hanging out the front pecan pie mm-hmm
mm-hmm
come pie you guys like I don't beep I
what it sounds like a Brendan on a bad
day what kind of pot you go oh I like
that
I like watching a woman eat a potato bra
let's just [ __ ] kiss me sound like a
big potato do that that that kind of
that's no talking ain't tiny sweet
potato the sweet potatoes are volcko you
don't want to save riders fertilize my
penis looks just like a sweet potato do
mine too yeah yeah can you google long
jams and make sure there's a Purple
Heart
yellow ones man Oh what you got down the
wrong yams in skin put keep put in
the purple star [ __ ] right there bro
yeah my [ __ ] looks like a newborn gerbil
laying down my [ __ ] looks like a shaved
rat chilling with his friends on the
[ __ ] in the Sun bro Wow Wow
damn bro I never realized that thank you
so much god I never realized that my
whole life I've always been looking at
my penis Mike what is this Romeo is a
potato bro and it is a yam brother
praise God hell yeah
[Music]